ja und ich begrüße sehr herzlich michael
kellner bundesgeschäftsführer von
bündnis 90/grüne der uns aus der schönen
uckermark zugeschaltet es weg guten
morgen herr kellner ja wunderschönen
guten morgen
was war denn jetzt gestern
ausschlaggebend oder in den tagen vor
gestern ausschlaggebend sich für
annalena baerbock zu entscheiden als
kanzlerkandidatin der grünen und nicht
für robert habeck
ja es war eine gemeinsame entscheidung
und klar ja wir haben zwei dies können
beide haben lange intensiv miteinander
gesprochen und am ende war es die
entscheidung einer werburg geht's nach
von für die letzten meter für diesen
bundestagswahlkampf als unsere
gemeinsame kanzler kandidat finden
unklar bleibt ja auch das was uns stark
gemacht hat in den letzten drei jahren
dieses zusammenspiel diese gemeinsamkeit
diese dieser teamgedanke der wird
bleiben ok teamgedanke zwei starke
kandidaten sagen sie trotzdem was war
das kriterium was war ausschlaggebend
dann doch annalena baerbock nach vorne
zu setzen ins rennen zu schicken und
nicht robert habeck
naja ich wissen sie ich will jetzt gar
nicht zu sehr aus den gemeinsam internen
debatten berichten sondern wir haben
eine gemeinsame entscheidung getroffen
und es ist sehr sehr gute entscheidung
und dass wir das in so einer
gemeinsamkeiten und seiner stärke und
ohne ohne verletzung schaffen
ich glaube das zeichnet uns doch gerade
als partei aber jeder werber ist die
berichte person für diese zeit sie ist
durchsetzungsstark sie ist entschieden
sie will was verändern sie wir neustart
für dieses land und deswegen bin ich
sehr froh als wahlkampfleiter von
bündnis 90 die grünen mit annalena
baerbock aber auch mit robert haben
gemeinsam in die sich in diese
bundestagswahl zu gehen
im gegensatz zu lala berbalk hat robert
habeck aber einige jahre
regierungserfahrung aufzuweisen
genau die hatte und hat auch viele
koalitionsverhandlungen geführt
und deswegen haben bleibt ja ein ganz
wichtiger bestandteil des teams und das
hatte er auch gestern selber wie ich
finde
in einem großartigen auftritt der viel
größe gezeigt hat er deutlich gemacht
wird da weiter unterstützen gerade auch
was die frage von regierungserfahrung
was die frage von
koalitionsverhandlungen angeht also
diese dieses zeichen veränderung ist
teamsport was wir jetzt die ganzen
letzten jahre gezeigt haben
das wird ja dabei bleiben schauen wir
mal auf den entwurf ihres
parteiprogramms der enthält sehr viele
vorhaben die auch einiges an geld kosten
ein grünes kernthema zum beispiel ist
der umbau der gesellschaft hin zur
klimaneutralität sie wollen auch bessere
kita ist digitale schulen bessere
versorgung in pflege und krankenhäuser
in der finanzierung allerdings bleiben
sie zumindest in dem wahlprogramm was
jetzt als entwurf vorliegt ziemlich vage
der nächste bundeshaushalt wird infolge
der pandemie ja er einen kleinen
finanziellen spielraum bieten wie wollen
sie diese investitionen die sie planen
und die für ihre ziele notwendig sind
wie finanzieren sie haben völlig recht
wir brauchen investitionen in die
zukunft in eine klimaneutrale wirtschaft
in gute infrastruktur in unserem land
und deswegen sagen ja auch in unserem
wahlprogramm
wir brauchen eine reform der
schuldenbremse wir brauchen einen
größeren spielraum des staates auch
schulden aufnehmen zu können wir zahlen
momentan ja praktisch keine zinsen auf
die schulden und deswegen sind uns
wichtig dass wir künftigen generationen
keine linie des klima und keine marode
infrastruktur hinterlassen sondern jetzt
geld aufnehmen um zu investieren aber
noch mehr geld aufnehmen es gab erwärmen
schon ziemlich viel geld aufgenommen es
gab erst letzte woche wieder einen
nachtragshaushalt er beschlossen wurde
dass es doch eher in den ohren der
wählerinnen und wähler ein
schreckgespenst oder nicht also ich
glaube die wählerinnen und wähler sie
merken doch jetzt unter corona wie im
brennglas wo überall defizite in unserem
land vorhanden sind sei es bei der
digitalen infrastruktur sei es aber auch
bei der verkehrsinfrastruktur die baden
wurde jahrzehntelang vernachlässigt aber
selbst die brücken sind marode in
unserem land
wir erleben doch wie schlecht
ausgestattet schulen und kitas in diesen
zeiten sind auch dass ein punkt wenn es
jetzt um fernunterrichts geht wenn es um
digitalisierung geht da ist doch ganz
viel aufholbedarf und wir sehen dass
eben auch im bereich von klimaschutz und
deswegen ist in der abwägung doch
richtiger jetzt zu investieren dafür die
schuldenbremse zu verändern damit
künftige generationen eine intakte
umwelt und vernünftige infrastruktur
vorfinden wenn für ihre partei alles
bestens läuft dann könnten sie
entscheiden mit wem sie als erstes
koalitionsgespräche führen mit wem sie
in verhandlungen gehen wer wäre das
welcher koalitionspartner also erst mal
sind wir jetzt wirklich für den nächste
schritt unserer partei entwicklung der
kämpfe um das kanzleramt fordern die
union um die führung dieses landes
heraus und ja wir wollen das
unwahrscheinliche möglich machen und
dass das gelingt und das entscheiden die
wählerinnen und wähler und danach werden
wir mit allen demokratischen parteien
sprechen um zu schauen was wir auf basis
unseres programms mit welchen parteien
damit wir das meiste davon umsetzen sagt
michael kellner bundesgeschäftsführer
von bunten bündnis 90/die grünen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch